all spruced up and ready for a new
tenant the Waimakariri District Council
has recently renovated two of its
pensioner housing units as part of a
pilot scheme it's more than just a lick
of paint the remodeled units boast new
carpet
kitchens laundries and double glazing
throughout some even have dedicated
parking and charging spots for mobility
scooters I think it's very impressive
and some modern colors and it looks warm
and inviting it's really good to see see
this upgrade not only are they more
attractive Jinga out from the council's
property team since the newly improved
units will save tenants money on their
power bill and be healthier to live and
we are really encouraging our residents
to have healthy and loving and with the
insulation and all the functionality of
the kitchen and everything we hope that
they'll have them you know and nicely
living conditions and you'd be proud to
have anyone here these units are part of
the council's pinch in a housing
facility in Clio eat smart in place and
were first built in the late 60s that
would do for a makeover
however originally only the kitchens
were going to be replaced because we
needed the removal of asbestos it was a
good idea to do more than just the
kitchen fit out so that we could update
all the insulation throughout including
double glazing and for windows and doors
modern building code requirements mean
that the units require reinvestment
affair to remain safe and functional for
the next 50 years if the pilot scheme is
successful and approved by council as
part of the long term plan similar
improvements will be rolled out for
council pensioner housing district wide
that would require a rental crease for
tenants however this would largely be
offset by government housing subsidies
and reduced energy and medical bill
we've got over a hundred units across
woody in Oxford Graham your own car boy
and most summer Philly old and so
refurbishing them and bring them up to
modern standards are things very
important for for the residents Council
will be considering the plan later this
year and if approved the renovations
will be rolled out over the next five to
ten years
[Music]